Alright folks, welcome back.
This is going to be kind of like the direction we're going to be going in the future with
the channel here.
I'm wrapping up the mentorship teachings for this model and we'll be just basically doing
reviews and index futures, Forex, commodities when it's applicable.
I posted that on Twitter as kind of like a short little promo and everybody was excited
thinking that I'm going to be doing like 30 different markets every single day.
It's not what I'm doing.
So kind of give you a flavor for what it is that we will be doing.
The mentorship group that I have with us, a private group, I no longer make videos for
them and one of the reasons why I started this project here is to steer people away
from wanting to buy videos that aren't going to help you anyway.
So when you're buying old videos, I'm talking about market moves for that particular day.
So it's not going to be as useful to you.
So to keep people from profiting off of pirated videos, I stopped making videos in my private
group and I make them here publicly.
Now some of my students are upset that I did that.
Others that understand why I'm doing it are in support of it.
I'm not going to argue or wrestle with the opinions of who's in support of and who isn't
support of.
I look at it this way, the folks that would have an issue with it, they're probably the
ones that are trying to sell pirated videos.
So now I've removed their market.
So you're a fool if you're going out there and you're buying all these Instagram guys
that are selling my videos, I got ICT mentorship 2021, 2022, 2019, all the way back to 2016.
You know folks, they're not going to help you because you weren't there when it was
given at the time it was given that's being mentored.
So that's what I'm kind of doing here and I'm doing on my Twitter account.
So that way we understand why I'm doing it and what motivates me to do it.
So there won't be a lot of markets obviously being covered each day.
I'll be looking at the markets that I was referring to either on Twitter or I actually
took trades in.
So it's not a matter of talking about something that no one expected me to have an interest
in, which is predominantly what you see here on YouTube and Instagram and Twitter and Facebook
and Discord and you know, the list goes on and on.
So today, one minute before 8.30, I apologize, I was waiting for my phone to update its software
and by the time I got back on to Twitter, I had one minute left to type out everything
that I posted and you can go on my Twitter feed and you'll actually see the post in here
too.
But on the economic calendar, there was a high impact news driver for Canadian dollar
and I said I would start working in Forex when there's a lot of you are specifically
interested in Forex because that's predominantly what I'm known for.
I've moved away from Forex recently because I wanted to be a part of the stock index futures
market and I'm still engaged obviously and then I did some live trades today and I'll
share some of that with you as well.
But I was covering the Canadian dollar and what I was outlining is kind of like this
idea and we're going to use it also to work within the scope of the teaching on daily
bias and we'll get into that at a later time in this video.
But right away when you look on the left hand side, this chart here is the dollar CAD daily
chart and on the right hand side, it's the hourly chart of the same pair of dollar CAD.
Notice what we saw last week, the market traded up, just bumped the short term high here with
that daily high.
What do we see once that occurred, what formed on that daily chart?
We're going to pause the video here, alright if you need more time, pause the video because
I'm about to continue.
When the market ran into that old high here, it hit it and the next day it created a lower
high candle.
So we have one candle, a higher candle high here on candle 2 and candle 3 or day 3.
So this is what I dub a swing high.
I'm not using a Williams Fractal on MT4.
I don't use MT4, this is not MT4 platform and 5 candles, if you're waiting for 5 candles
you missed the boat.
So this swing high at an old high, did it run it?
Not by much but it did.
That movement right here is shown clearly on the hourly chart and the following day
creating a high that has a lower high than the highest one that ran into that old high.
So we have a 3 bar pattern, one candle, the lower candle to the left, a lower candle to
the right, that's a swing high.
Pretty simple stuff.
Then the next day, I'm going to be expecting the market to trade lower.
Now here's the problem with this particular market.
Yes it's likely to trade down and with the benefit of hindsight I'm showing you here
but again I tweeted about this beforehand.
So at 8.29am Eastern Standard Time you can see that is on my Twitter feed.
If it's dropping down we have this down close candle here.
So it could be met with some resistance digging into this range of this down close candle.
About half of its body right in here and not surprisingly you can see that's pretty much
where we close that candle here on the 21st of June 2022.
So when we look at this dashed line here what I'm anchoring to is the opening on this down
close candle because that is a bullish order block.
Now I'm not suggesting that we went into that to go higher.
I'm just saying that as we started this down move it's digging into this candle so that's
going to be the impediment to a big sudden one big candle that would take us down into
this area here and clear out this.
So over to the hourly chart you can see last week we ran up into it started drifting lower.
Fairbait gap here it rebalances to that drops back down consolidates between this high and
the low here comes back in drops once more attacking the cell stops here consolidates
once more breaks digs into that order block.
Again that's this level here so watch what happens it goes into it overnight then it
rallies this rally here is ahead of the 830 news driver on the economic calendar you can
find it on forexfactory.com but this movement here this is all manipulation that takes us
up into an imbalance here fairbait gap running a short term high buy side has been taken
when it runs here that's anchored above this short term high.
The chart on the left here is a 15 minute time frame for a dollar CAD and the chart
on the right is a five minute chart.
On the economic calendar you can see at 830 in the morning June 21st 2022 we had a high
impact news driver for core retail sales and medium impact retail sales number.
Yellow events I'm not interested in red or medium impact high or medium impact those
are the news drivers I'm looking for so if we look at the price movement on the five
minute chart you can see that once we ran up initially at seven o'clock in the morning
what is seven o'clock in the morning New York time that's the beginning of my ICT New York
kill zone it's extended to ten o'clock in the morning when it's forex so seven o'clock
to ten in the morning New York local time the market creates a short term high then
runs above that so we have buy side taken then the market drops just below here but
I want to have a more meaningful displacement okay we want to see something that's more
energetic this little toe in the water type thing here that's not enough we want to see
it fall in okay so it drops down that short term low here that's your shift in market
structure energetic displacement and that candle is exactly when that news driver came
out at 830 so all of this is news driver related economic calendar manipulation and the market
is going to cause people to want to sell short and chase it going lower it creates
a fair value gap in here on the five minute chart but there also is a fair value gap here
now ahead of the news you might be thinking well couldn't you have sold short here yes
you could have but the economic drivers that come out at 830 could have sent it up higher
and taken us into this area here so really it's a matter of waiting for the news to hit
the market and then create the setup that's a little bit more conservative there are times
when it's so obvious that they're going to continue to move that starts ahead of the
new driver but it takes a little bit more experience to find those setups and trust
them I would rather you use your demo account to see these types of moves real time wait
for them to form and then go in and engage in with your demo not try to forecast how
much of a move it's going to further increase higher or lower once the new driver comes
out or the news event hits the marketplace relative equal lows down here there's your
sell side so we had this fair value gap formed after buy side was taken here but now this
creates an area of buy side that once this trades lower we have this fair value gap and
then we have this very bad gap so it could run up into that level with the volatility
so you're gonna have to make sure that you have that defined with your risk management
the draw on liquidity is likely to pull down then here or into this fair value gap and
we'll talk a bit more about why that's the case but eventually trades down into it bagged
and tagged sell side liquidity the tweet I posted again you can see this at 829 a.m.
June 21st 2022 I just made it on Twitter but basically saying good morning folks dollar
cad is about to have some volatility note the sell side and buy side on your five and
15 minute charts sell side is here buy side would be here study if it wants to run sell
side before buy side or rebalance to a discount what does that mean at the news driver release
it could go up and bump the buy side then dig in for the imbalance here that's a discount
or run the sell side out here so all of this movement up since five o'clock in the morning
New York local time this was just ahead of that news driver here so they were building
in a premium then during a New York kill zone it gave you to set up by teaching this model
delivered to the fair value gap and delivered to the sell side of the liquidity pool between
this high and that low here's equilibrium so we have to find a discount array below that if we're
going short that's the fair value gap here you can take a partial there and target the sell side
liquidity which you can see it does that as well here and here I tweeted failed actually include
that tweet and we should have put it in here now but I mentioned how the market reacted here like
that and I stated that's the reason why you want to take partials because you don't know if it's
going to come all the way back up and then revisit this fair value gap and lose the opportunity to
bank something when it goes into your first opportunity discount array when going short
now I've dropped down into a four-minute chart and I dimmed the fair value gap that I mentioned
earlier that you could have taken that trade but it'd be ahead of the news driver and it's a little
bit more riskier but you wait for the displacement short-term lows taken then we have a shift in
market structure and the imbalance would be between this low of this candle and the high
of this candle in here now by itself this is a rather elongated imbalance so all of this sell
side delivery is imbalanced and there's not enough buy side delivery so it's going to want to wait
for the market to come back up in here in Forex there is no central measure of volume okay and in
the algorithm that delivers price that is going to want to come back up and overlap this down move
and offer buyers an opportunity to get in on that this is too much of a movement one-sided so the
rebalancing so if that's the case where in this range would we be looking for for an entry knowing
that this fair value gap could be revisited and you're gonna have to utilize that for your stop
loss so your stop would have to be here doesn't matter where you're going short in between this
low and this high you have to define the risk with the stop here based on the model I'm teaching you
now some of you like oh this is too much you know because if I went in at 129.45 and I put my stop
here that's almost 12 pips that's too much no it's not it's all relative you can scale that's one of
the benefits of Forex it's very scalable whereas if you're trading futures you're kind of stuck to
whatever the contract size is and you got to either make it work or you can't take trade or
you're basically being over leveraged which is what you don't want to be doing so if we look at
that range from that high down to that low and drop a fib on it we're gonna get a measurement
of 50% here that's our equilibrium price point so really we need price to get to that point or
higher so by definition we could be looking for a short here up to here and that would look like
that so that was that's really the range that you'd be wanting to sell short in so you're not
really risking a lot of pips but you're defining the entry a little bit better even though it goes
above it a little bit that's okay but the bottom line is that eventually gets in sync watch the
bodies of the candles support that premium high of the imbalance beautiful delivery then it starts
to break lower one more time false little rally takes buy side liquidity once more then the real
move starts to unfold trades into the fair value gap here take partials so that way if this reverses
on you you're paid and it drops below a low where engineered sell side liquidity would be and then
digs into the sell side liquidity over here so your entry could be 129 44 129 47 in that range
anywhere near is reasonable it's acceptable obviously the closer you get to this level you
may not have been filled it might just leave some of that open and then start to roll over but as
you can see here goes a little bit further that's fine that's why we have to utilize this level here
for our stop-loss based on the models roles that I've taught in the 2022 YouTube mentorship
all right so I have a four-minute chart here with all the details shown sell side liquidity pull
relative equal lows from the morning it rallies up creates a high after running buy side liquidity
it breaks down consolidates it gives a short-term swing low here with an energetic run lower
at the high impact news event at 830 rebalance stop goes here and it rolls over during the 10
o'clock till 11 o'clock but that time frame 10 to 11 that's London close so if you're looking
for directional plays and you're in a trade you want to have about 80% of your trade off between
10 o'clock and 11 o'clock in the morning because usually not all the time but usually that's when
it creates the opposing end of the daily range so if it's creating the high of the session here
the low was likely to form between 10 o'clock and 11 o'clock that's algorithmic now there's
sometimes if there's news events sometimes Canadian dollars influenced by crude oil numbers
and that would sometimes skew this time window 10 to 11 so on those days when there's crude oil
inventory numbers coming out and I'm interested in trading the loony I will trade with the
expectation between 10 o'clock to noon and not have such a tight little window of 10 to 11 and
I promise you I have students for days and days and days and years and years now that will confirm
that this has not just been form-fitted for this example I've always taught that 10 o'clock to 11
o'clock in the morning is London close profit-taking hour I'm quite sure if you go through the older
teachings I have in this YouTube channel you'll probably actually hear me talk about that very
thing as well all right so we're going to talk about the e-mini S&P futures contract this is the
September contract for 2022 if you're following along on trading view and I hope you are the
symbol you would be utilizing for calling up the data for this contract is ESU 2022 okay and that
would give you this chart here this is a daily chart and before I get into it I want to talk a
little bit about daily bias okay so this topic is one of the most requested topics that I would
cover and I have done many teachings on it I've done amplifications I've done revisits to this
idea and I know what you're wanting okay because it's what I wanted as well you want a simple ABC
it always works it's always going to be the same way it's always going to be the same procedure
process and it's always going to give you a winning trade now some of your already folding
your hands and hissing because you're like oh that's not what I want that's not what I want
you're exaggerating Michael no that's really what you want and you want me to give you a very simple
cookie-cutter approach to find daily bias and I want you to understand that I've taught these
things many times throughout the lessons and lectures and series that's found on his YouTube
channel this is the simplification that I make for daily bias if you stick to these rules you
will know how to find daily bias as I teach it my students follow these rules okay I'm going to
go through them with you and you're gonna be kicking and screaming and saying there there's
something else you're holding back there isn't it's experience it's doing it yourself but the
keys to daily bias are simply this everyday bias is unrealistic if I go in looking for a specific
predetermined daily bias before the market starts trading invariably I'm gonna have it incorrect
notice I said that I'm not perfect some of you hold me up to this hero level status and I'm not
a hero okay I'm just somebody that knows what they're looking for and knows how to avoid
hopefully making the same mistakes over and over again because I'm looking for a procedure in process
that will lead to an outcome that generally not all the time but generally yields a specific result
so I'm not trying to get a daily bias every single day I'm trying to determine the likely
weekly expansion and again what is that I utilize a weekly chart and I studied that and I want to
see does it look like it's gonna run to an old low does it look like it's gonna run to an old high
or is it running to a imbalance below the market price or is it trying to run to an imbalance above
the market price or is it likely not to move because there's no data for it for that week
and other markets have high-impact or medium-impact news that would be more interesting and the
algorithm will be working those pairs or markets and the pairs or markets that don't have a high
impact or medium impact driver will probably be a lackluster market environment I'm looking
for the direction of an expansion move I'm not trying to get the entire weekly range I'm not
trying to buy the weekly low and sell the weekly high I can but that's not what I'm trying to do
you don't need to do that okay I know some of you hate when I do that but I'm trying to make sure
that you understand there's a distinction between what you should be coming into this with in terms
of expectations and what is realistic okay in the beginning all you're trying to do is determine
is it likely to expand higher is there going to be a big move a flurry of activity going higher
during the week or going lower during the week and by itself that is huge in terms of what you're
trying to pick now you might be wrong because sometimes I get it wrong but I'm looking for
some volatility in a direction based on what I'm studying on a weekly chart so this is a
daily chart shown on this slide here the same thing I would be doing to determine where the
daily charts going I'm trying to do that with a weekly chart but I'm only interested in seeing
what's it likely to reach for I'm not trying to predict the weekly closing price on that
candlestick I'm trying to look for where is the bulk of that volatility going to be pushing higher
or lower and why would it be like that and it's as simple as what I mentioned earlier is it aiming
for and gravitating towards an old high to run above it or is it gravitating towards an old low
to run below it or is there an imbalance where it needs to come back and revisit that because it
might just drop down to a fair value gap to go higher longer term I don't even need to know that
all I need to know is what direction is it most likely to have the majority of the volume pushing
through now when I say volume there is no centralized volume number in 4x when I say the
volume that means the the interest the chaos the energy all the activity the action okay is it
going to be on the higher side reaching for buy side or is it going to be on the lower side reaching
for sell side that's what I'm looking for I want to find where is it likely to gun for this
particular week who's in the crosshairs have people been making money going long is there a
low that they're gonna try to run down and stop them out with it that will be enough for me to
frame an expansion going lower so I'm looking for obvious liquidity in that direction below
lows above old highs or identifying imbalances in price delivery top down that means from the
weekly down to the daily down to the four-hour down to the one hour to the 15-minute chart and
then once we get to the five-minute chart you do the scalings from five four three two and one
whichever has the clear obvious fair value gap for you based on the models rules and I focus on
days that have high or medium impact calendar events only so if you go through your economic
calendar in fact you can look at next month's economic calendar they're already there where
are the high impact or medium impact news events for the markets that you trade what day of the
week and what time so if you have a news driver that's coming out on a particular day say Tuesday
or Wednesday and you're expecting the weekly range to expand lower well on those medium impact or
high impact news events I'm going to see hopefully something that is going to run up higher go into a
fair value gap or run above a short-term high run stops and then break down show displacement
then create a fair value gap and I'm going short on that
and I'm doing that and looking for that setup and that directional price run inside my kill zones
intraday at the same time the economic calendar is suggesting a high impact or medium impact
news event is likely so what did I just teach you here I basically said that there is absolutely
no expectation on my part to know the bias every single day of every single calendar trading day
I'm only focusing on these sweet spots these low-hanging fruit days where everything's coming
together all the stars are lying okay I'm looking for the higher time frame weekly to
expand in a specific direction that starts my bias then if I think it's going to be going
higher going lower for a specific target or imbalance then I'm going to go to the economic
calendar to look for when that might occur now there may be a move that happens prior to the
economic calendar event occurring and that's just going to be a missed opportunity so you have to
use something else some other pair something else that you got to trade with sometimes that occurs
but you'll see that there's a lot of opportunities using this criteria and it's very forgiving for
you as a developing student because it's already given you permission not to know the daily bias
outside of these rules see you want to trade every single day because you want to be the
everyday trader I don't want to be the everyday trader the everyday trader is the everyday trader
is more prone to have losing trades because they are trying to do something every single day when
there are times when you should not be trading at all and that's what makes me different from all the
other educators out there because I have made a career out of knowing how not to destroy myself
because that's what I did when I was a 20 year old I thought that I could trade every single day
and that's problematic when you don't know how to trade and you have a lot of time or
lack of self-control and that's why I was blowing accounts when I was 20 and 21 22 that
fevered pace of I got to do it I got to do it I'm going to miss that next move when hopefully
you've seen now enough instances where this pattern repeats a lot over the course of a month it's in
most markets a few times a week but if you notice those moves are occurring when there's a high
impact or medium impact news driver on the economic calendar so it's something that you can plan for
you ever hear them the old cliche remarks of books and educators they say plan your trade
and trade your plan well this is how you can do that with that model you look for the economic
calendar the time of day what kills own in the market you're expecting an expansion higher or
lower in that weekly chart there it is you're looking for these things to repeat and if you
start journaling these things you're going to notice that the setups this is one of the epiphanies
okay because I know some of you just don't want to do this but now because I'm going to tell you
you're going to go into it hopefully and see that what I'm saying is true if you backlog
every day show everything that took place mark up your charts as I'm going to show
you in some examples in here when that happens over time you're going to see that the best
setups occur when these calendar events are in play and they originate around that same time
and what will happen is is it'll convince you to say okay I don't need to be the everyday
trader I don't need to be in here being super scalper I don't need to be in here trying to be
an olympic trader because trading is not an olympic sport it's not an olympic event
and they don't give out gold medals for overtrading but they do blow accounts
so eventually doing that enough and if you don't know what you're doing you're going to blow your
account and that's hopefully what I'm trying to prevent you from enduring
all right so we're looking at the hourly chart here on the S&P obviously we've traded down
we left relative equal lows but this low went just a little bit lower than that one
that's all we need it hit that and it started retracing higher this movement here
that's whipsawing both sides of the marketplace sell side taken then buy side taken and then it
broke down whenever I see price action like this I ignore the both side type movement usually it's
FOMC or some kind of rate announcement type event and that's what you're seeing here when I see that
I ignore that wick and I ignore all these as well the real range is here this is manipulation
this is manipulation it's already done it's not going to hurt you focus on this swing here
so when the market drops down it creates this low runs a little bit lower we're consolidating
we had a holiday on monday the market starts to drift higher and what I'm concerning with
this run here is this high to that low and I'm getting my range equilibrium is here
so if it's going higher what's it reaching for well it's going to go into a premium
and this right here this imbalance I'm not really interested in that one because
it's overlapping with that equilibrium 50 percent level of the high to that low so I
want to see it dig into a premium so even if this is going to go up to go down
I want to know do I have an opportunity to see it go up into this area here or maybe even up here
so we'll use the first low hanging fruit approach here so we have a fair value gap there in balance
sell side only the market's going to want to revisit that area this is exactly what I teach
you this is exactly what happened look at the bodies of the candles yes there's a little bit of
movement just above this candle's low but look at the bulk of these candles the bodies
they're staying within that range that's defined by what I teach you as a fair value gap
in a premium market what makes it a premium it's above the 50 percent level
so it's going up into that level here and it's consolidating
on the 15 minute time frame pause the video look for what you can identify
based on your understanding and experience learning under me so far
okay if you need more time pause the video
all right so here's midnight new york local time we had a fair value gap here bullish order block
these last three down close candles that's one consecutive order block
it digs into the order block with the fair value gap hits that during the london session
it rallies up we create a fair value gap here it runs by side here and then creates relative equal
then creates relative equal highs ahead of the new york session so the market drops down
goes into the fair value gap here into the last down close candle bullish order block there
that's where you could be a buyer ahead of the 930 opening why would you feel confident to do that
because we already have an energetic price run from london open the market started at midnight
and went where did it go up no it went down into an imbalance and then there was
a lot of energy off of that so the market created a short term shift in market structure
here that's bullish london creates the higher the low most of the time 70 percent of time you're
going to find that that is true if your directional bias is correct so i'm trusting that that low
is probably pricing in the daily low this retracement into the new york session
we're trading into an order block we close up this fair value gap then we rally a little bit
and drop back down into the fair value gap once more creating optimal trade entry that's not what
we're going to focus on this one here but we have the new york am session beginning here from 8 30
in the morning to 11 this is specific to index futures for the morning session
this is the upper level on that fair value gap on the hourly chart and this is the lower level
on the hourly fair value gap so that's your targets it's going to draw on liquidity
the market runs from the fair value gap here to the low of the fair value gap on the hourly
chart to the high of the fair value gap on the hourly chart after clearing by some liquidity
on a five-minute chart there's a lot of things going on here you can see we have a low then we
ran that low once more then it rallies and moves up away from the order block and then back down
into the last closed candle on the five-minute chart so there's an hierarchy of how the market's
trading down into a higher time frame to a lower time frame to a lower time frame all being
supported by down close candles within the bias that's bullish and once fair value gaps are being
closed in the market goes higher so it's signaling to you it's indicating to you that you don't need
an indicator you don't need some wonky little gimmicky candlestick replacement okay the
candlestick is telling you everything you need to know you don't need to have any kind of indicators
no moving averages none of that garbage okay everything is being shown here in price action
relative to time and price so we have the market starting with a run from this low with a lower low
so what took place here we'll come back to that in a minute the market comes back down into a
short-term discount relative to the low to the high here discount rallies and at 9 30 it's
consolidating and then it starts to run reaches for the bias of liquidity here
the low of the fair value gap on the hourly chart and the high of the fair value gap on the hourly
chart as draws on liquidity three targets all hit
i'm going to zoom in this is a zoomed in chart of the session that starts
at 8 30 and going into the 9 30 opening so we have the low here lower low into the order block
it rallies short-term shift in market structure here comes back down in there's an imbalance or
fair value gap here these levels are based on the five-minute chart so even though we're
looking at a smaller time frame than that that's what we're looking at but we're going to refine
that down into this particular time frame so inside that let me go back up one more slide
so inside the fair value gap we're dropping down in here but we're doing it into this fair value
gap there down close candle that's an order block and fair value gap there it is
you can buy this right there and trust that it's not likely to take that low out why
because we already had a stock running event here low lower low sell side taken reaction
off the order block we're into the fair value gap we rallied once more we created a fair value gap
here drop down that last down close candle you can be a buyer there there's buy side liquidity
resting up here that's going to be your initial draw on liquidity so that'd be a first partial
if you want to add if you want to pyramid the position
you can add that as it starts to run up higher but i want to show you the low to the high here
that's 50 or equilibrium market drops into a discount prior to that run up here this
consolidation at 9 30 we see it taking off here it's already done the move of manipulation
knocking people out retracing then off to the races so this is a case where you do not need
to wait for 9 30s opening to get that volatility to get these types of manipulation moves this
is an early setup discount fair value gap and rallies so notice what's happening we have an
hourly discount that we're trading into here then it creates a short-term discount relative
to this low to this high that's what we're seeing here then the market rallies here
here comes back down into an order block and fair value gap discount rallies consolidates ahead of
9 30 is it likely to trade back down and take that low out no because it's already closed in the only
fair value gap that's here see that so if you're up here looking back it's already rebalanced this
there's no reason for it to go down it doesn't need to go down here because it's already shown
Williams to want to rally and this run didn't need to go over here because this low took out
that low so that is all framework in narrative so all that comes together now also couple that with
the 8 30 news that took place in the dollar cad i'm showing you how these two markets
relate to one another with the proper context and bias dollar cad what is the currencies
first pair in its name dollar so if we're expecting as i was hinting at on twitter
it going down to a discount or running sell side liquidity that means the bias is bearish
so if the bias is bearish on dollar cad that means that it's a risk on scenario so the markets like
s&p nasdaq other foreign currencies are going to be easier to rally versus going down and dollar
pairs i'm not really interested in anything except for the dollar cad because dollar cad had the
high impact news event so i don't need to go to the dollar itself when i have a high impact news
event when dollar cad i can go right to that and cut to the chase in terms of what the bias is for
the morning session because if i'm likely to see lower prices on dollar cad that's the same thing
as saying lower dollar higher foreign currency and when the dollar goes down it's easy for
spooz or e-mini s&p stock index futures to go higher and everything i've shown here is in concert
with that idea so here we have that short-term high shift in market structure after the stop hunt
retracement to a discount the fair value gap buying here run to initial target buy side liquidity
relative equal highs here it runs that you can't see it here remember we were dropping down this
is a three-minute chart now it rallies up creates a fair value gap here overshoots it a little bit
that's fine rallies once more and digs into the high of the hourly fair value gap
and again kind of like what i was suggesting moments ago here is that movement up in the
e-mini s&p at the nine-third time period when the dollar cad was trading down into its discount
here so lower dollar cad higher s&p so as a forex trader you could be selling short if you're not
forex trader you could be selling short if you're not an s&p trader
or if you're not trading forex like me this is the long on s&p and you can add in as it's taking
out this short-term high here you can look for pyramid opportunities and what would that look
like well i was in a 10-second chart i know some of you were surprised when i said that
but here is the 930 opening here and we had a little bit of consolidation then we had a run higher
creating the fair value gap between here and here the market dropped down i'm buying there
it rallies up into that there's my entry you can see it right there that's the fill
that's the price 37 41 and three quarters and as the market goes higher if you're trading like
this you can take part first partials at logical levels as i mentioned we were on the higher
time frame charts and as it goes higher you just scale off what your model what your approach or
your plan would allow for and then hold something for the rest of the day towards the close or
at least try to see if you get a continuation into the afternoon session and that would be
between 130 and four o'clock in the afternoon new york local time so hopefully this has been
insightful to you hopefully it has helped you obviously in terms of using other markets for
intermarket relationships for bias how to navigate markets these are the only two markets i've talked
about today and you can see how they had a synergy between them there was a a movement and kind of
like a dance between them even though they're not correlated don't think that there's any kind of
correlation between them it's the fact that it's risk on risk off that's all that it is and i was
focusing primarily on dollar cad because dollar cad had its high impact news drivers for today
so i was using that in relationship to what i would expect in the s&p market and i found my trade by
utilizing a market i'm not going to trade but if it's going to give me insights and it's going to
go lower it helps me frame risk on risk off risk on that means foreign currencies index futures
stocks go higher dollar goes down risk off is dollar higher and everything else going down
so if you go into your day with those ideas risk on risk off it makes it a lot easier to look for
supporting ideas with intermarket relationships correlations between assets like if you are
trading like forex euro dollar versus cable euro dollar would be a better trade than
say pound dollar if there is an inability for one of them to go low make a lower low
and one doesn't do that that's showing you that's the relative strength leader that would be the
better buy in this situation here another instance would be aussie dollar and kiwi dollar
in new zealand dollar if you're looking at situations like this and you find a currency
that fails to make a lower low intraday when it's risk on you would be buying the risk on higher low
currency and i don't i didn't see i didn't look at the australian dollar and the kiwi this morning
and it may not have presented it but if i were trading those pairs and i wouldn't really be
trading them because the impact news driver on the economic calendar is again one dollar cat so
that's the market i would be trading so a lot of you ask all the time like how do you know which
pair to trade how do you know which one to pick i'm starting that with the economic calendar
but sometimes i may use that market for instance instead of being dollar cad today if euro dollar
had high impact news event i would compare pound dollar and euro dollar for correlation
so i would look for smt divergence to signal which one i'd rather be in just because the news driver
is in for instance the euro the better trade may be in pound dollar if they both went down
prior to the news event coming out for euro and if pound dollar failed to make a lower low i'm
buying pound dollar because they're going to most likely move in sympathy with one another because
they're closely correlated but in the instance of dollar cad i'm not going to do anything except
for focus on dollar cad because the economic calendar suggested that's where the volatility
would be for forex today and you're welcome to go through the pairs and compare and contrast
whether that's true or not i didn't do it but you can do that on your own and hopefully you've got
something out of this one until i talk to you on thursday for our discussion on money management
that'll complete the 2022 mentorship teachings and we'll just continuously do market reviews
on the youtube channel monday through friday so i'll obviously be back lord willing tomorrow
on wednesday with a review on something either s&p related or some kind of forex pair
and hopefully you'll learn something from that as well until next time be safe